the last time i was here it must have
been a couple years ago
um
i got chased by those [ __ ] swans out
front
yo
so
so i didn't know a whole lot about swans
right and i was looking at him i was
like that bird i go and i i was like
what a pretty bird what a pretty bird
and there was somebody who was working
here it was like
this one the swan
and i go yeah i go you know what's so
crazy they don't they don't fly away
when people come up
are they cool if you pet them and he was
like yeah you should go touch
he was lying
i walked up i don't know
i walked up to that swan
and i was yo okay so
i'm
just who i am
if it's a wild animal i'm
i'm i'm not gonna i'm a little nervous
anyways i'm not i'm not gonna be like
yeah i'm not those people like you guys
seen those videos online of the people
like at yosemite and the grizzly bear
comes and they're like hey [ __ ]
bear and every time i'm like oh i hope
that bear [ __ ] eats your face you
dumb [ __ ]
so i walk up to the swan
and i was like hey
hey it's my
name have you seen those
when they do that [ __ ] thing it's
like my college girlfriend when she got
mad [ __ ] [ __ ]
this thing started swinging its giant
[ __ ] dome at me i was like holy [ __ ]
so i
mental note right
don't [ __ ] with swans right
well apparently
geese are in that same category
so i was out in st louis um and um
i was with my dog and we were on a road
trip together
and um
by the way this dude uh he's half
bulldog half uh half american bulldog
half pit and he's just a good looking
dude but had never been on a road trip
and we had never gone out
and so we stopped on the side of the
road together to pee
and um
i'm peeing and he was super curious
and was standing there and just
walked right in front of me and turned
his face right into my [ __ ]
yeah and he was just like ah
yeah
yeah that's what that tastes like all
right yeah
and so he but he was really curious
about those geese and so there was there
was a field full of geese next to a
hotel
and um
they were just like
super chill and he was running around
you know i was throwing a ball and [ __ ]
and
he kept looking over the geese like you
mind if i
do you mind if i run over there
and i had heard about geese [ __ ]
people up
so i was like
yeah i'd like to see that
i mean i know who my money's on but i i
don't know for sure you know
so he starts to run over right
he oh yeah
yo he starts to run over and he was so
you know how pit bulls kind of have that
smile
right and he was running over and he
even turned over his shoulder smiling
his tongue went out of his mouth and he
was like i'm gonna [ __ ] them up
he was so confident and he started to
run at him right
and this is not a small dog
and he's [ __ ] fine
[Music]
and so he's running these geeks across
the field and there was probably i don't
know 15 of them
and 13 of them flew away
and two of them turned around
and started to run at him and i was like
what the [ __ ] is happening
he had the same look on his face he was
going up full speed but when they turned
and started to run at him he started to
slow down like what the [ __ ] is it
and then they got probably within 20
yards and they got up on their little
and they you know you know when they
[ __ ]
you know when they go karate kid on you
they [ __ ]
and both the geese just [ __ ]
like that
yo this dude went from full
sprinter he put the brakes on
did one of those wide turns
and started running back at me
yo if he could have spoke this is what
he would have been screaming start the
van
start the [ __ ] van you know what i
mean
he
he was scared out of his mud
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]